se ci sono le canzoni che canti in
chiesa no ci sono quelle anche che canti
all'inferno voglio dire che secondo me
questa si canta all'inferno vabbè
l'ultimo episodio che ho fatto sul campo
dal mio punto di vista doveva essere
l'ultimo cioè della serie non avrei mai
più toccato ma questo gioco c'è qualcosa
che non capisco che mi porta a giocarci
se come se fosse una droga il titolo
tazza testa che ho messo stavolta è
semplicemente la traduzione di cappelle
letterarie in italiano molti dicono
coppa testa ma in realtà lui era una
tazza se guardi bene sta roba piramide
per il ma non è che voglio
ok quella con la maggiore va beh mi
dovrebbe rappresentare la madonna scotta
frate crea fa a proposito di canti
inferno e di cantini chiesa e vorrei
farti poi vi domani anzitutto perché sei
arancione come donald trump
ti sei accorto che ti manca alla z e
pensare che c'è chi fa sul gioco senza
mai neanche essere colpito una volta io
li invidio le invidio queste persone
perché sicuramente troveranno la [ __ ]
che è un piacere
sei un simpson non è quello che pensavo
cosa sto vedendo ora che qualcuno mi
spieghi per favore questo vedo mai i
quali quale marcia di lsd vi siete fatti
prima di programma sta roba
ma porca vacca già stavo per schivare
non so come si tira il missile al cielo
sbloccato ma non sono così eccolo lì
avrò fatto un po male spero ma qualcosa
mi dice di no
la orca vacca sarebbe molto bello
riuscire a finire un boss al quasi primo
tentativo perché un ora che sto giocando
il numero delle madri ma non è finita e
volevi adesso c'è quello finale
finora abbiamo solo scherzato il
problema che mi rimane una vita ragazzi
[Musica]
agghiacciante ho guardato stavo tra
l'altro che peccato ancora quel che dice
all'inizio che non ho mai capito o help
line editor sto gioco un tormento con
tua madre mi addormento non capisco
finito ha preso spara i gatti sto tizio
mai un parente della sapri gamer mi
chiacchie sfilò de anche la famiglia
occhio ragazzi ho notato che le persone
che danno più fastidio al mondo sono
arancioni mai giusto dubbio chi
sostenuto la ulti per il boss finale ma
non credo che mi serva a qualcosa
effettivamente prono a sparargli mi si
stavo scherzando buona dovrebbe
andarsene dovrebbe andarsene dovrebbe
andarsene saranno problemi
ok occhio ovvio che questa è buona
occhio che questa è buona
[Musica]
no no no no no non l'ho colpito lorca
van os peccato il missile cosa colpito
era va beh no no no non è fattibile
ragazzi ve lo giuro infattibile sono
pure riuscito a mancarlo cioè vi rendete
conto
[Musica]
madonna la donna mamma mia non ci
speravo mai per una personale
obiettività sono tanti avrà una famiglia
una bella ragazza ma games di jimi si
chiamava aveva la j e lei vicino come si
permette regalami delle monete ti prego
sono povero tua sorella morta cos'è sta
roba mausoleo 2 anche se quello dove
devo difendere il la copa de tizia che
dovevo fare il ferry per il ornitorinco
sventurate per fornitori sco no niente
non finisce mai durante un perfetto
grazie grazie
cosa ho vinto ciao zio alla fine
mausoleo niente un livello con altro è
contento manco avesse chiamato io e
lockett dyou super single e ha quindi
diventi muller abile per un pochettino
ma questo è uno dove devo imparare
ingrandirà negandogli adoro vi giuro
c'era negano sono il top del top di
soggiorno questo mi fa male lo so io per
ora è invece più invece è invece tua
sorella
ma poi con che musica di sottofondo me
lo stai dicendo gioco
la donna che macchia che strage di addio
ma con che coraggio tornano dalle loro
famiglie i creatori di giochi che
coraggio vanno a casa dicono moglie ho
programmato giusto oggi niente che mi
deve rompere le palle sempre
se proprio di ariano viceversa come ci
arrivo lì col pences con la forza del
pensiero di gesù aiuto ma come ci arrivo
ma come non ci arrivo qui che ho fatto
qui game dio sia lodato fatto quiz game
no io non ho parole ragazzi di giuro non
ho parole non ho parole
non ho parole ma non ci arriva
non c'è cosa mi chiari di tutti sa che
sono al corso di fashion avanti mi hanno
giudicato come sono tardo nell'anima
sono tardo per due
mamma mia che fastidio c'è qualcosa che
si flash come l'ho dimenticato e potevo
flash armi in avanti c'è io ho giocato
finora senza ricordarvi che potevo flash
armi e che era una cosa fondamentale che
grazie al bene non ci sei arrivato qua
prima come fate a non ricordare mi sta
roba è basilare però dimenticatelo
fotoflash armi di portarci mia come si
sa le quattro che chi è questo oggi
[Musica]
l'ho fatto l'ho fatto io posso andare
non mi devi far male una vita sola potrà
incazzarmi aiuto una vita sola chi sei
tu definisci ti sono invincibile sul
visibile ma che vai vai vai forte sega
potesse bene ci siamo arrivati con dei
punti di vantaggio rispetto a prima
[Musica]
quanto schifo aiuto morirai prima o poi
brutto schifo sei un pretzel no a tua
madre morta
[Musica]
non riesco ad attivare la mia su ben
profilati nuovo nemici militavano vinto
ma non trovo il tasto per attivare il
tasto a non è difficile
[Musica]
ora gaò 4v quattro vite 4so arrivato web
quattro vite incredibile lo far finta di
averne una per quando faccio interne una
demoni per mamma mi ha schivato ci
arrivò qualche neo 0 non faremo comunque
torni civile c'erano com'è possibile
allora quello è stata sparate robert e
sei bellissimo solo giuro che io ho
fatto il livello perfetta adessso senza
usare neanche la super 5 carte non usa
perfect run e molto 20 volte più adesso
fa da perfetto run
non credo di aver preso la perché non ho
fatto i perry però c'è stata a perfect
randa
voglio dire sono riuscito a fare ci più
altri 2 basta basta va bene così basta
faccio il registro qualcos'altro per
bello il ponte un utile mi fa andare
avanti nel gioco non se non si fosse già
sullo kata la strada 18 sembra vi sia
piaciuto video ragazzi basta così per
oggi sono contento di esserci riuscito
va bene così assente ragazzi veramente
piace anche vari social come della
sinistra cosa ho detto ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo visto bene
[Musica]